las células inmunitarias circulan de
manera constante por el cuerpo vigilan
ciertas sustancias en la superficies de
las células llamadas antígenos
las células sanas tienen antígenos
diferentes de los de las células
enfermas o de Los Invasores extraños en
el cuerpo
las células inmunitarias suelen ignorar
los antígenos de las células sanas pero
cuando las células inmunitarias se
encuentran antígenos en los gérmenes
destruyen el germen por ejemplo algunas
células inmunitarias activadas reconocen
el antígeno de las células infectadas
del organismo y luego las destruyen
otras células inmunitarias activadas
llamadas células plasmáticas producen
moléculas llamadas anticuerpos
estos anticuerpos viajan a través del
organismo y se fijan solo a los gérmenes
que tienen su antígeno específico esto
marca el germen de la destrucción